you've never been on a chair on that air
conditioner what do you guys think of
this helicopter
oh they're gonna love it yeah you're not
scared
Rendon are you by the way mr. Trump here
we are on your helicopter have fun guys
yeah you're in your helicopter yeah I
said hey already and we're ready to take
you which is you almost as a person
we're gonna have a good time
okay great kids all right guys you ready
I don't think rick santorum ever did us
like that to me
nice guys you know like he just needed
it from the synchrony so you can forget
you boy Bishop somehow you got a lot of
angry people out there YouTube that's
why you're highly paid I'll show you the
two most silent that's right I think
that's what it takes
taking a picture because I love Iowa and
I love these children they greet you
we have a lot of we're gonna go down for
my brush sometimes there's been a
backlash against rich candidates like
Mitt Romney any chance of that we media
third well I don't know he wasn't rich
and I don't really
people like you see the people in Iowa
so no matter how much watch the
slightest mark but it
it's very truck right speak I
is an amazing place
how do you like that kids okay
you see the new balls in the scanner
thirty-four percent I mean
but you know where we were four years
ago
the bottom of the
all that Rick Santorum
they're not big
I've never run for office before I love
I have a lot of love to the people and
having a good time seems like you're
having fun
Bremen
you pass that point a giving now you're
clearly going to go through all with you
tell em number one in every single ball
and by double digits and medication said
we're having a good time and the people
are agreeing with my message
gonna make America great again you're
staying into the end
I wouldn't even think about not I was
hoping you wear jeans you own jeans
you'll own jeans